[Music]
today we're trying different sports with
the wrong ball first up ping pong with a
golf ball
oh this works well yeah it's oh hey guys
let's try this one
yeah just try it out i'm sure it works
next up volleyball let's play a match
against last cnn what's our tactic i'll
do all the diving i'll do the saving and
then you
finish it
to 10 points here we go
yeah now we're getting it now we get it
okay i thought
yes
[Music]
nice you think
okay
you take
nice
[Music]
emma what are you doing down there
okay let's finish them
10 different sports 10 different free
kicks me against lusty
that was a professional fake this is an
easy one
no
volleyball
oh what a save i think you can directly
just give up on this one no no way
no he's not going to save that one oh
this is easy
adrenaline where are you
you saved it like it was nothing
[Music]
yeah you almost saved it you ready last
time yeah i'm ready
check this safe look at this
it all comes down to this one
[Music]
you can hop in for one i kick it from
really far
[Music]
basketball with an american football
that's right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
that was a bit too easy basketball
crispy
[Music]
okay
it's football
[Music]
baseball basketball
[Music]
and by the way 82 percent of you
watching haven't subscribed so make sure
you do it now to help us get to 5
million
that took a while next one let's try
which ball works best for tennis serve
with the bouncer ball do i want to be
here no i don't i definitely don't want
to be here
it'd be dangerous maybe
what how is that possible and the
extreme bouncy ball baseball shot is
still coming up so make sure you watch
until the end we're gonna need some
bigger balls for this one super bouncy
ball
straight in the face it's three times
bigger than the racket oh nice
come on it's still in play i know
this is the best ball so far
[Music]
but that's why it's called an exercise
ball
we are here on the golf course and we're
gonna draw which ball each one of us
gets american football volleyball table
tennis ball
my ball is the only one that actually
fits in the hole it's the wrong way
my shots i can do however i like
good shot mick i'll go with an iron show
it
it's continuing into the forest that's
in a good place
whoa
oh
look at that calculated shots
i could say that it's not mika who's
winning this
fourth shot
yes i think that's my fault so far
no way
good shots
doesn't count
whoa your best one at least i look like
a pro golfer don't i
no
come on he bounced over the center pit
this is clearly a shot for that racquet
thanks mike good cutting
no hit the tree behind the trunk
he's for sure going to hit the stump are
you 100 sure yeah i'd like to say 200.
he got it
it went over very very proud of you emma
that was very good
how did i get it too far you've got to
have it land in the hall i don't think
something you've got it's cool female
have you played golf before you've got
to get it in there oh yeah true
[Music]
the next one you just have to lift it
my turn i mean that's probably the rule
shoot him away no it's me
let's take it home not the amount of
shots
oh yes
now it's your time to win the game
the winner let's move away from here
with a floorball
[Music]
oh
oh it's so broken look at this bouncy
ball is pure chaos
it looks very dangerous
[Music]
what is going on
it's going to come here
like i said welcome to the box
it sounds very risky
you broke the chair
i was just testing if the bench works
okay i think i'm done with this maybe
that's dangerous enough so next up we're
going to try baseball we have an
ex-professional hitter and a
professional catcher
i'm good i'm good first ball shuttle
[ __ ]
[Music]
touchdown home run hockey puck
wow you're hitting them quite well so
i'd say we move on to more difficult
ones i'll try and catch it yeah
american football
whoa
we've got it pretty far with the other
balls but i think the bouncy ball
should be the one that takes the victory
i think this white line is a good goal
like if we can get it here
that must be like 150 meters you ready
otto
go
[Music]
[Applause]
i found a bouncy ball 200 meters away
from the hitting area i think this might
go the furthest if i can get a clean hit
on it i think there is a text on the
golf ball it says i think it says
subscribe subscribe it's a pumpkin do it
okay
whoa where did it go oh
[Music]
really it did
luckily
the building well i sliced it that could
have been lethal the winner of the
baseball challenge was the bouncy ball
or the golf ball oh wait oh we still
have the bowling ball oh
okay
[Music]